we've reported so many times to you that
Congress will not allow the government
to study gun violence it makes no sense
it's horrible we should be studying it
closely since it's such a huge issue in
American society and Democrats and
Republicans appear to have come to terms
on a bill which would as a sort of side
effect of what the bill really does
allow some government study of gun
violence and it would be the CDC that
would actually do the studying and
there's been language for decades that
has de facto prevented the CDC from
looking into the issue and it's
important to understand that the CDC was
not contrary to some talking points that
you hear the CDC was not strictly
speaking banned from researching gun
violence but they were banned from using
any federal funds for that research and
where the line is money being fungible
and homogeneous it has basically
resulted in the CDC saying we're not
going to get involved in that what we're
now seeing is that Congress is dealing
with a 1.3 trillion dollar spending bill
they've got to pass it by Friday to
avoid a government shutdown it's not
going to really do anything about gun
safety laws but it has two items in it
that would allow research into gun
violence more easily and it would also
increase background checks just slightly
which is a good thing okay
Democrats are considering this a major
win and I hope that that's what it will
be and the thing about researching
issues research is a double-edged sword
right if you research very polarized and
political issues you have to be willing
to accept the research if it's done
fairly and fully right assuming it's not
bogus research and you've got to be
ready to act on the results of that
research and sometimes we support
research with the expectation that it's
going to give us one result then it
comes back and it gives us a different
result and an important tenet of sort of
the scientific method skepticism all of
that stuff that we talk about is if the
data conflicts with your pre-existing
beliefs
you've got to revise your beliefs and of
course this assumes that the data is
accurate and that the research was done
properly if I were presented with
information people in the audience know
my view
guns if I were presented with
information that truly indicated it was
good research indicated beyond the
shadow of a doubt that gun violence is
merely a problem of not enough guns give
people more guns we're gonna solve the
problem I'd reconsider and revise my
beliefs Pat are you ideologically open
to changing your view about guns if the
data tells us hey you know what they're
right arming teachers
no more gun-free zones let's do it all I
am ideologically open to that if that's
where good data points I think it would
take more than one study though as yet
we can compare the rates of other
countries yes ours so it wouldn't just
be that one piece of research but I'm
open to changing mind the body if the
consensus of well done research pointed
in one direction I think that there are
lots of people that generally speaking
want more gun safety regulations that
like Pat and like me
would be willing to revise those beliefs
but along the same lines if the gun
fetishists are presented with evidence
that suggests that listen the best way
forward is you got to reduce access to
certain types of guns reduce
availability you need stronger
background checks you need whatever
right a gun registry I'm just making
stuff up here it's not the point they
need to be open to revising their
beliefs and the truth is they know or at
least predict that gun violence research
is not going to help the pro-gun cause
because if they believed that the
research would help their cause they
would allow it they would welcome it the
NRA has been blocking government
research into gun violence for a very
long time now if you ask them they would
say it's not that we're against research
it's that we know the research that
would be done would be biased and would
be used as a pretext to ban guns you got
to ignore that for a moment because
that's that's it's not defeasible you
can't change their mind because they
would say no the research would be part
of the problem I don't think that they
are intellectually open to revising
their views and I've made it very clear
I'm super open to it send me your
thoughts you can also this discuss this
on our subreddit at david pakman.com
slash re d di t quick break back after
this today's program is made possible in
part by fruit or fruit or is a social
forecasting game where players come
together and compete with each other
to predict future events you open up the
game on your phone or web browser you'll
see a whole range of forecasts covering
topics across the board from politics to
sports and everything in between you
wager on predictions about real-world
events using for tours in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
and improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account
and follow me by clicking the link in
the description if you're watching this
on YouTube
this week on futur I pose the question
will there be a congressional hearing
regarding the Trump sexual assault
allegations what do you think click the
link in the description and place your
bets and you can browse the politics
category on futur to wager on other
predictions sign up now at root or calm
and start making your forecasts on
political topics and tons of other
topics totally free available on both
Android and iOS as well as on web
browsers that is fut you you are calm